we begin here in germany where the
government has announced it is
activating an early warning plan in
preparation for possible shortages in
gas deliveries from russia economy
minister robert habeck said a crisis
team was being established to closely
monitor gas supplies this follows
moscow's demand for payment and rubles
which germany and other importers have
rejected habek who's from the
environmentalist green party also urged
german industry and households to try
and conserve energy
we
we're in a situation where i have to say
clearly that every kilowatt hour of
energy saved helps
and that is why i would like to combine
the triggering of the early warning
level for gas supplies with the appeal
for health to companies and private
consumers
you are helping germany you are helping
ukraine when you reduce your use of gas
or energy in general
einstein our political correspondent
julia saudelli is with us now outside
the german ministry of economy julia
what is this early warning plan and what
does it mean that they've activated it
so this is part of a three-step
emergency plan for energy
here in germany this uh that was just
activated right now the early warning
alert is the first step of this plan and
what it means in practice is that
the state is not really getting involved
in terms of managing managing energy uh
distribution and and in the country but
it is going to form a crisis team that
is going to be made up of uh the
ministry uh the economy ministry other
authorities including uh the energy
net network agency here in germany but
also energy companies and
this crisis team is mostly going to
monitor the situation here in germany in
terms of of gas
deliveries and gas distribution and is
going to have to deliver regular reports
uh in terms of the situation and uh the
other two uh steps would only be
activated if the gas situation would be
to worsen
to worse and julia germany has
repeatedly said it would not stop
importing energy from russia due to its
dependence how concerned is berlin right
now given this step that moscow may shut
off its gas lines
well what has been made clear is that
there is no reason to panic after this
decision this is just to be prepared in
case of a change in russia's gas
deliveries to germany what the
government is waiting for is this a
deadline set by russian president
vladimir putin he asked his government
the central bank and energy company
gazprom to come up with a plan to
implement the payment in rubles of
russian gas now the g7 governments
including germany have said they will
not pay for the gas and rubles this goes
against the contracts to deliver gas
from russia to germany and so the
government here is waiting to see
what decision might come out of moscow
tomorrow in terms of these gas payments
but
they are not immediately concerned about
um the gas deliveries uh stopping
immediately they're just saying that
they are preparing in case what else did
he say that stood out to you julia
well as we heard in that sound bite he
stressed how it would be really
important for people and companies here
in germany to start reducing their
consumption
obviously that is a big topic and he put
it into the perspective of not only
helping germany at this moment but also
helping ukraine now the government has
said and robert the economy minister
specifically have said that germany
cannot immediately do without russian
gas they are working to
reach a point where they can do without
it in the next few years right now
they're trying to reduce the
the the use of it but it will take time
so it would be important for for now for
germans themselves to take a step and
try to to reduce their consumption
dw correspondent julia saudali reporting
thank you very much
further analysis of this decision to
activate an early warning plan should
there be gas shortages in germany dw
chief international editor richard
walker joins us now richard germany
looks to be caught on the back heel here
a little bit after years of being
criticized particularly the previous
government for their energy policy
yeah that's right and that criticism has
been international but also here in
germany um that
germany simply allowed itself to become
far too dependent on russian sources of
energy oil and gas also coal but
particularly natural gas where as we've
been hearing uh the
the usage of natural gas even exceeded
50
from russia at times and it's quite
interesting
um to watch robert harbeck so the
minister has been announcing this he is
the minister really in the middle of all
of this action about trying to find
different sources of energy because he's
from the green party and he's basically
been saying we told you so about this
dependence on russian gas the green
party of course with its agenda of of
tackling climate change wants to reduce
fossil fuel use altogether but in
particular it's been very very critical
of russia and in fact he was hosting um
an international conference uh yesterday
here in berlin on the transition towards
cleaner forms of energy and he used very
stark language about russia germany's
dependence on russia describing it as
being stupid that germany in hindsight
um
enabled this kind of level of dependency
to to
develop and kind of this this problem
having been on two levels first of all
too much dependency on any one country
and then secondly too much dependency on
this specific country um too much belief
that russia might change um that when
you build an interdependence
with another country that that you
foster a more positive relationship that
this has simply not come to pass and
particularly the fact that the nordstrom
2 gas pipeline which became emblematic
of the debate around germany's
dependence on russia that this was even
built
after russia annexed crimea illegally
back in 2014 i think this is seen as the
really the the greatest emblem of this
failure talk to us a little bit more
about minister habik he was recently in
qatar he was recently in the uae seeking
out new energy deals it seems that
germany has backed itself into a corner
again as he said this was a stupid
decision policy planning with regard to
the previous government and now they're
being forced to turn to these countries
in desperation yeah um but
they have to i mean
the united states has said that it will
it increase supplies of energy to europe
but that's not going to be enough to to
meet the fall short and the full
shortfall um so robert habeck has been
in the middle east visiting countries
which have been criticized very strongly
by his party for their
records on human rights and it's been
interesting to watch
on that tour he was making instagram
videos trying to explain to his um uh to
the german people like his thinking in
doing this and i think he had a couple
of points on the one hand he was saying
well you know still any relationship
with any of these countries is not going
to reach anything like the dependence
that that um the level of dependence
that germany had on russia
but also some of the thinking that
reflects this german attitude to what's
been called vandal deutsche hanel this
attitude that you can kind of change
countries through trading with them some
of that was visible in what he said in
qatar for example where he started
talking about he had been raising issues
of workers rights workers representation
pay and things like that and hoping that
that would change in qatar so some of
that old german thinking does still seem
to be there dw chief international
editor richard walker thank you richard
i'm joined now by rob watts from dw's
business department rob germany has long
been criticized for its reliance on
russian gas now moscow is demanding that
berlin pay in rubles why is moscow
asking for this you've got to bear in
mind that the russian economy is in real
trouble from the sanctions that have
been imposed you know they've got
inflation of over 14 percent uh you've
also got the fact that the ruble has
lost 40 of its value since the start of
the war and that's what this is really
all about now one of the ways that you
stabilize a currency which the russian
government really needs to do
is to increase demand for it and one of
the ways you can increase demand for it
is by forcing people who spend a lot of
money with you to spend rubles with you
so that's one of the things behind what
uh president putin himself because he
announced this himself is is pushing but
also you've got the fact that you know
sanctions uh make it much harder for
russian organizations russian
individuals as well to deal in euros and
dollars if they want to trade them with
other countries because there's
sanctions in place to stop that so again
by getting more rubles in they start to
find a way around those sanctions and
that's actually why you're hearing from
from the germans you're also hearing
from other europeans the g7 that this
would undermine the sanctions if germany
would start paying in rubles
talk to us a little bit about how
concerned berlin is right now that
russia might turn off the pipes
uh well
we we do have this deadline tomorrow so
it feels like something very imminent
but you know this is stage one of three
we've got this which is i suppose an
early warning alert and then you've got
the next stage which is an alert level
but it isn't until the third step that
the german government actually starts to
step in and to start to make policy that
means that households but importantly
businesses have to change how they're
using their gas so most likely to be hit
by that first would be heavy industry
steel makers because households would
ultimately be insulated from this as
much as they could be but we would start
to see real problems with how germany
can export its products and you know we
already have all kinds of supply chain
problems in the global economy so it's
not something that anyone wants to
happen but
we are now starting on the road in that
direction talk to us a little bit more
about households what kind of impact
is going to be you know felt by germans
living here
well i mean
you know the cost of gas in europe has
increased fivefold in the last year and
that's a big way in which germany gets
the energy to households you know 15 of
germany's energy comes from gas around
half of that actually does come from
russia so as a result of that gas prices
go up that means bills go up and we're
already seeing that germans
can't help but notice that their energy
bills are already starting to rise and
we are seeing that have a big impact on
people's mood here i mean there was a
some research published yesterday on
consumer confidence here in germany and
it's fallen through the floor in the
last month despite the fact that we've
seen coronavirus restrictions being
relaxed that should have been something
that provided a boost and things should
be looking up in germany but actually
people are starting to be pessimistic
not optimistic
dw businesses rob watts thank you very
much for your insights rob